[SPEAKER_00]: All right, you follow the voices, and I can describe the passageways to you later, but basically you take a right and then a left, and you're crawling along the wall.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, right.
[SPEAKER_00]: A right, and then you turn left, and you come to what you think is a council room, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because your homunculus can look into it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there's a big table that has like a map engraved in it.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you realize it's a map of the Azure Seed.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this is obviously the place where the admirals come and talk tactics or something like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: In one of the seats in the room, you see Lord Fairwind sitting there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Talking to two Suel, obviously, Toli people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Toli?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And you hear Ferenwin say, Don't worry, they'll never be able to get through the defenses here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Your hobgoblins will be able to keep them off.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you think this attack will succeed, obviously it will not.
[SPEAKER_00]: One of the Toli says,
[SPEAKER_00]: We're not worried.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, we think we have most of what we need from the caves below.
[SPEAKER_00]: It seems, Lord Fairwind, that you've taken most of the chemicals for yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll have the rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll take them to our island, to Kane Toli's island, Lord Fairwind says.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our deal is still in place then.
[SPEAKER_00]: You will vouch for me on the council.
[SPEAKER_00]: Forcing Prince Jeon to give me more of the profits from his trade with the rest of the trader nations.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli says, one of the Toli says, yes of course, you'll be well compensated.
[SPEAKER_00]: After this
[SPEAKER_00]: When the pressure on Prince John ends, everything will go back to normal as it was.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll return all of the barrels of the, um, well, the pest control, as it were, and you can go about your business as usual.
[SPEAKER_00]: Until then, we'll store it in our location.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you realize?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do I realize?
[SPEAKER_01]: Are you asking me, like, what do I think?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: About the chemicals?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm thinking that of the chemicals that I had found earlier, that yellow stuff, wasn't it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, that's what I'm thinking.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I don't have any proof.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't see a barrel full.
[SPEAKER_01]: You don't see a barrel of this stuff, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: But that's my most logical connection.
[SPEAKER_01]: What did that stuff do again?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or what did I think it did?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, if you remember the letters between... My mom and... And... My dad.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was... Basically, it killed Sahaugin.
[SPEAKER_00]: It poisoned the waters to make sure that they could never come near.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it was used in the wars against the Sahaugin 150 years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: I gotta remember all this.
[SPEAKER_00]: And your father...
[SPEAKER_00]: Was trying to figure out a way to make it because they didn't know how to make it.
[SPEAKER_00]: They got it from the Duke of Berghof.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, the truth about this is this is a very big secret because everybody thinks that Helm Island has a magical enchantment that makes sure that the sahaugin cannot attack Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I want to keep it that way?
[SPEAKER_00]: The question is do you?
[SPEAKER_00]: And the question is, do you want to keep Fairwind's treason a secret or not?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh no, I'm gonna rat.
[SPEAKER_00]: His fate is sealed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would Jeon be mad if I...
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I think he would be upset if I had proven that it's not a spell, it's chemicals that's actually keeping them back?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I mean, I don't think he wants you to yell it from the rooftop.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, the problem with this stuff is the fact that the supply comes from Burkoff.
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's a weakness.
[SPEAKER_01]: What is that?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Duke of Berkhof is the Plar that's on the inland side of things.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's one of the Plars, the two Plars, the Plar from West Keep and the Plar from Berkhof, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Prince of Toli is Suel, but those two guys are Suel too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Berkhof is a very ancient and strange land.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was allied with the sea principalities, the pirates, 150 years ago and actually gave them
[SPEAKER_00]: Society in a way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, sophistication, weapons, stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was an alliance between them and that's what caused all this to happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not really sure about everything, the details of it, but obviously this was part of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not going to tell them about the chemicals.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't think I should.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I'm going to say that Fairwinds are talking to Toli and that they're in there and he's evil.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.